here we go again Sony have revealed the
7/3 Games will be receiving as PS Plus
subscribers during the month of February
2018 you can get your hands on all these
titles from Tuesday February 6th oh and
like usual one of the Vita titles is
available on your ps4 let's start on the
ps4 and the flagship game of the month
rime a puzzle adventure title set
moments after a shipwreck has watched
your lifeless corpse onto a mysterious
island filled with puzzles and
brainteasers to discover and solve most
consists of fetch quests and basic
jumping puzzles but some use perspective
in simply brilliant ways to breathe real
innovation into the game the lack of
Bert is great and helps immerse you into
the simply gorgeous fantasy world but if
you didn't like similar games like
journey or eco well you won't like rime
the story is pretty compelling and if it
hooks you the 5 to 7 hours of play will
fly past in seemingly seconds ryan
receives very mixed reviews on its
release a few months back with both
outlets awarding the adventure between 6
and 7 out of 10 the most favorable
review I could find was a staggering 9
out of 10 from the magazine electronic
gaming monthly our second offering on
the ps4 is Mac the platform of beat'em
up released in late 2013 if I had to
describe knack I would say it was a
blend of crash bandicoot and the old God
of War games but it doesn't do either of
those very well but hey we try to look
at the positives here one of the
greatest things about nak is his ability
to grow in size and strength after
locating these mysterious relic things
this gives nak the strange is power to
one minute be small enough to perform
covert stealth missions and the next
he's bigger than an actual building
fighting super-powered mechs it's weird
and hopefully it's your kind of weird
there are even situations where nak
takes on the characteristics of Mirrors
are even flaming logs to burn through
locked doors looking at the review
scores Eurogamer and GameSpot threw this
one under the bus with four out of 10
scars but keep in mind the only way you
really know if you're going to like it
or not is by downloading
February and giving it a try you may as
well it's free
the psvr title for the month continues
to be star blood arena a multiplayer
shooter which sits you in the cockpit of
a battle pod and orders you to murder
everyone else like I always say about
these virtual reality titles download
them while you can even if you don't own
VR one day you might and you'll already
have a back catalogue to play through
over on the ps3 and spelunker HD a six
player online race through caves this
one is absolutely huge in Japan and even
set a sales record back in 2009 the HD
version offers 100 humongous caverns to
traverse across ten worlds and look at
this if you remember the 80s I do they
were bloody great there's a classic mode
to resemble the original versions of
spelunker on your journey you'll be
evading enemies unlocking vaults and
amassing treasure beyond your wildest
dreams I get that it doesn't have bags
of character but it's bloody good if you
can force yourself to try it in fact
could you do me a favor and comment
below if you still download and play ps3
games on PS Plus I'd really love to know
thank you
next on the ps3 is Mugen souls II or
Mugen souls Z depending on where you are
in the world a Japanese RPG in which you
will hunt down and defeat a dozen gods
filling the shoes of Surma a tiny little
goddess girl who really enjoys beating
things up
there's 9999 levels of growth to unlock
so get started straight away and you'll
be finished in time for Christmas
I think you may need to be in love with
JRPGs to play this one but hopefully I'm
wrong please let me know your thoughts
over on the Vita is Graham Kingdom which
can be played on your ps4 too this is a
strategy title in which you will join
the war for the continents future think
of it more like a tactical RPG and
you'll be closer to the real mechanics
up to four characters in your squad sit
on a chessboard like battlefield then
take turns attacking or defending in
that respect the actual battles play
very similarly to the South Park games
you may have seen recently over 12
chapters you will rinse and repeat this
function earning new squad mates new
weapon upgrades amongst so many other
things if that's your bag grab it on
February
onwards and finally game number seven
exiles end is our last offering on PS
plus exile Zend is a Metroidvania style
2d platformer it's a simple formula
explore kill things find new stuff kill
things find new areas kill things the
story is the usual survive the alien
onslaught while waiting for help to
arrive so nothing very cinematic there
but the art style will be appealing to
Metroidvania lovers exiles end holds a
steam rating of 6 out of 10 so there we
have it 7 games to get our teeth into
over February what floats your folk to
this month I imagine from PlayStation
grenade sorry about my voice and
hopefully it will get better soon
it's great to be back I'll see you next
time
[Music]